usually people are really confused when
I tell them what I do I tell them like
yeah you want a fingerboard company like
those tech tax used to get in summers
like you have a professional
[Music]
skateboarding makes me feel awesome it
doesn't get boring it's always a
challenge there's no rules finger
boarding and skateboarding both have
that
[Music]
[Applause]
I started fingerboarding in 4th grade I
had a lot of fun playing with the tech
decks and then I wanted to kind of
improve them a lot of times the screws
would come out so I'd glue them in and
just start modifying things like that
and I just realized I could make them
better and better a lot of kids wanted
to buy them so I kind of put a name on
it and it grew into this huge business
over time there's hundreds of thousands
of people out there that are into this
we are at the flat-faced rendezvous
location in Dracut Massachusetts and
it's pretty much a big building filled
with fingerboard parks and I do huge
events here where kids fly in from all
over the place to come and fingerboard
together when you go into a contest
that's crazy because there's stadium
seating and there's everyone looking at
you and lighting and cameras my first
few contests I got a crazy adrenaline
rush like you don't even remember the
thing after you do your run I don't do
any warm-ups or exercises with my hands
for fingerboarding apparently some
people do calisthenics the rules are
pretty much you want to use two fingers
you'll have maybe 30 seconds or a minute
or so and you just do a run and there
will be a whole bunch of judges they'll
judge you on consistency style the
tricks you do it's like really high
pressure you can't even really put it
into words it's a crazy kind of feeling
and atmosphere when so many people get
together from all over the world all
over the country and some of them it's
like a really really big deal to them
like that's the only thing they wanted
to do all year it just makes me super
happy because I can barely believe that
I'm the reason they're there like
because of something that I set up and
that I'm doing in the skateboarding
culture you get a lot of people in
general that are different you're just
kids that want a place and want to be in
there
everybody else is right Chris Worley is
the founder of a skate a nonprofit that
teaches kids with autism how to skate
for it autism has a lot of aspects to it
most of the kids need occupational
therapy of some form skateboarding is
similar to other therapies they're
learning how to control our body in
motion and it just stimulates parts of
the brain that you need to be stimulated
in order to do things in life in order
to have conversations in order to pay
attention
I have a son who will soon be 14 his
name is Sasha and he was diagnosed with
autism at 22 months old I bought him his
first skateboard when he was right at
five years old his brother was three it
was really difficult for them to just
come together and play there was no play
somehow the movement of the skateboard
just made him focused and they would
just skate and I want to do that for
other families Chris started a skate
eight years ago in a church parking lot
in Birmingham Alabama it's since
expanded across the US and
internationally this year they were
invited to participate in the Dew Tour a
pro skating contest in California where
kids were paired with professional
skateboarders I've known Sasha since I
got involved with a skate about five
years ago the joy that I see that it
brings kids like that's where I know
that there's
is what I'm supposed to be doing the
skateboarding culture is accepting of
everyone in our spectrum or not spectrum
no one cares what color type gender
whatever it is like you can skate you
can stay and we got love for you it's
really incredible to see kids change
through our program I see families just
see their child who is now capable of
something
in a way forming a skate is like a love
letter to Sasha
[Music]
kind of like a skater has a skateboarder
BMX has a bike I just saw the wheelchair
does something fun so why not take it
into the park I'm Erin wheels fathering
him and I ride w CM x w CM X stands for
wheelchair motocross it's you know
taking your chair into the skate park
and hitting ramps kinda the same thing
as BMX but with a wheelchair I first
started going to the skate parks when I
was eight years old and I've been doing
it for 16 years now
the wheelchair is definitely just an
extension of my body because skaters
aren't always on their skateboard and
bikers aren't always on the bike but I'm
always on my chair so that gives me like
an unfair advantage to just practice
everywhere I go I feel like I'm lucky
but I always have my wheelchair with me
because I can just jump whenever I want
I was born with spina bifida I've had 21
surgeries throughout my life and I spent
a lot of time in the hospitals and yeah
it would be easy to just be bummed out
on that but I was for me I just found
the positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time in 2008
I got the Guinness world record for the
first backflip on a wheelchair now is
that a local competition here in Vegas
called am Jim
that was a pretty cool day one of my
favorite tricks is just simple hand flip
because I always loved watching skaters
do it when I was growing up and you know
watching the pros do it it just was
something I wanted to learn
[Music]
I'm very blessed to be able to do what I
love what I'm passionate about for a
living a lot of the time the wheelchair
comes with the stereotype of you can't
do this or whatever because it's a
medical device
I just always seen the wheelchair is a
great opportunity I feel like there's
like a glass ceiling for women because
I've hit it if you skate and you riff
then you should just get what you
deserve if like skateboarding is
supposed to be for everybody if we do
actually want any form of equality or
space like we're gonna have to be the
ones to create that space my name is
Lacey Baker and I'm a professional
skateboarder I discovered skateboarding
when I was really really young like two
years old I was in foster care at that
time and I would watch my foster brother
escape a mini-ramp and I just was like
immediately obsessed like I was like I
have to do this I started competing when
I was 11 years old when I was 22 I
skated the 2014 X Games in Austin and
that's the year I won the gold with
women and skateboarding there's like a
subculture within a subculture the ski
industry like just doesn't care about
women's skating it's not equal for
example like there is a skateboard
contest series which didn't use to
include women in it but it just started
to
however the prize for first place is 30
grand and like for the guy's first place
is 200 okay I feel like it should be
because we work just as hard as the guys
mio skateboards is a company that was
created to like support women in
skateboarding I do my own board graphics
like I do a lot of the other girls board
graphics and like it's rad cuz it's like
skater owned and it's like for us and
it's like bhaiyya
so it's like there's nothing corporate
about it and it feels like like that's
how it's supposed to be even if nothing
comes of like like having asked a career
or like anything like that like I still
have skating and like I believe in being
yourself and like you know just doing
whatever the [ __ ] he won that's what
skating is supposed to be when we
started to go after Greg's dream of
being a professional longboard life
changed a lot
you're out with your father you're just
out there having fun like nothing really
beats that like chasing after the same
dream I think that's the best part about
it for sure this is Mike Papp rawski
he's my father he does downhill
skateboarding along with Street luge
this is Greg Papp röszke he's from
Golden Colorado
he's a downhill skateboard downhill
longboarding is basically going down the
hill as fast as you can
Street luge is very similar to long
boarding except you lay down Greg still
is the youngest to competed at the Pikes
Peak downhill race here in Colorado
Springs the fastest I've gone today is
70 miles an hour but that's that's about
it
2011 my ex and I were going through a
divorce it was a big adjustment for
Gregg
he was lashing out physically and having
problems in school I needed to try to
motivate him and get him on the right
track
they told him if you get your stuff
together in school we can go after any
dream you want to I decided I want to
pursue longboarding because it put me in
the zone and made me forget about all
the negative things that were happening
in my life at the time so I bought him a
leather suit for Christmas that year and
and our first year on the scene we
traveled to Canada New York Washington
California we were at the Ohio gravity
games we rode the free bus to within 5
miles of the event and then we loved all
of our luggage down there it started
raining on us we had a two-man tent
that's all we had and as we were cuddle
up in that tent with all our gear and
everything Gregory said to me he goes
dad he never told me the dream was gonna
be easy and it it was at that point I
knew this kid's got it he understands
like he gets it just being able to be at
the very lowest with my father and the
very highest we know that we can tough
out anything together and that we can we
can make it
I've seen great grow a lot since we
started skateboarding a lot of people
look at something and think oh I can't
can't do that Greg looks at it and says
how am I gonna do
[Music]